what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out Pro and today I will be
breaking down the most recent events in
the black hole or story and boy do we
have a lot to talk about we just saw
full power Dante go toe-to-toe against
full power Yami and you better believe
that Yami was able to surpass his limits
with unbelievable results during this
epic battle we also got some very
important information from Dante
information about how demon power works
and also we learned that hasta and his
demon might be unique compared to all
the other demons and demon magic users
this information could have major
implications on the future of the story
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
black lower content here on the channel
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
an amount Pro or you just haven't
subscribed yet make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
finally this video will contain black
clover manga spoilers we are talking
about the very latest events in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned
so at the very end of the previous
chapter the story suddenly switched
focus from the battle against vana
Kaimuki Kula to the ongoing fight
between Yami and Dante despite the fact
that Dante is a member of the dark triad
and judging by his large crown he might
even be the strongest member of the dark
triad Yami was more than holding his own
in this fight Yami kept landing powerful
hits on Dante and Dante had no choice
but to keep healing himself using that
fleshy magic that he himself thinks is
ugly Dante even admits that Yami is
strong enough to force him to take this
step even though he doesn't like using
this magic and this is an important
point in and of itself it seems to me
that Yami is certainly the biggest
challenge that any of the dark triad
members have faced during this war by
far and
a result of Yami's incredible power
dante is forced to use all of his demon
power in order to continue to fight
against Yami the latest chapter begins
with Finn Rahl
absolutely shocked at the extent of
Dante's strength when he reaches his
full power and for a moment FINRA
wonders whether he should try to help
Yami or maybe try to find the other
magic knight captains and bring them
here to support Yami
however Finn Rahl is unable to do
anything because he can feel that if he
tries to move even a little he will
instantly be killed by Dante Dante is
now using 80% of his demons power which
is the maximum amount of demonic magic
that he can currently use as a result
dante undergoes a transformation that
darkens most of his body and more than
half of his face is now covered in
demonic darkness Yami is put off by
Dante's demon mana but no one can deny
Dante's power he is an absolute monster
in this new form at this point dante
explains why he is only able to use 80%
of his demons power and why the same is
presumably true for the other two
members of the dark triad the following
information may vary depending on which
translation you look at and if there is
a correction in the future then I will
address it in the next video but from
how I understood it the demons were
possessing Dante and the other members
of the dark triad are not fully in this
world the demons who are possessing them
are still partially in the demon world
and for that reason the dark triad
members cannot access 100% of their
demons power this will continue to be
the case as long as their demons are
partially stuck in the demon world
but if they can somehow open the door
between the two worlds the door known as
the tree of cliff Thoth then they will
be able to use 100% of their power this
information shines a whole new light on
Dante's master plan which he revealed to
us several chapters ago when he told us
that he wants to open the gate between
the two worlds
using the tree of cliff off I assumed
that this just meant that he wants to
bring more demons into our world to
possess more people but it seems that
part of the reason why Dante wants to
open the portal is so that he can
finally use 100% of his own demons power
if this portal is opened then his demon
and xenon and Monica's demons will no
longer be split between two worlds and
so they will be able to manifest their
full power inside of this world but
that's not all
Dante also says something else that is
very interesting and something that
could have massive consequences for the
rest of the story dante says that he's
not sure about the demon who is
possessing austa he's not sure if his
power worked the same way as the power
of the dark triad demons this implies
that there might be something
fundamentally different about
Asta's demon could it be that because he
is possessing Oscars grimoire rather
than aster himself the anti-magic demon
doesn't have to play by the same rules
as the demons were possessing the dark
triad is it possible that Asta's demon
can actually use all the 100% of its
power without the tree of cliff ah we
obviously don't yet have enough
information to know for sure but this
suggestion that oz does demon is somehow
special that it is unique compared to
the other demons is incredibly
interesting to me and I'm guessing that
it might play a big role at some point
in the near future now using his full
power which at this time is 80%
Dante creates an incredibly powerful
spell which he calls gravitation
singularity the spell appears as a black
ball almost like a mini black hole and
it begins destroying everything in sight
the ball creates a massive crater around
everything it touches the ground the
forest and even an entire mountain fin
Rollins shocked to see that everything
that this dark ball comes into contact
with seems to disappear without a trace
again it is as if this ball is
swallowing matter much like a black hole
Yami tries to counter Dante's attack
with his dark cloaked dimension / but
Don
today's spell is able to twist the slash
itself which prevents the attack from
being effective Yami and Dante continue
to fight in a truly exciting battle
between two top tier mages and warriors
Yami keeps trying to find a way to
counter this gravitational singularity
spell that Dante is using but nothing
seems to work
this attack seemingly can't be cut
because it just er generates and it
keeps destroying everything around it so
for a while all Yami can do is dodge
while trying to think of a way to stop
Dante at one point
Dante's spell even manages to graze the
right side of Yami space which leads to
Yami's face dripping with blood the
black bulls are deeply concerned when
they see all that blood on Yanni's face
and when they see how unstoppable
Dante's spell appears to be but our boy
Yami is not giving up in true Yami style
he vows to surpass his limits and he
says that if he can't surpass his limits
and rise to the challenge then he can't
call himself a leader with the black
Bulls watching Yami is more determined
than ever to overcome of this seemingly
impossible challenge he manages to hyper
condense his mana into a single
overpowered dark magic attack called
sudden death he then prepares to attack
Dante with this new spell but before
Yami can even use his sword to attack
Dante the sudden death spell fires a
dante like a cannon from a distance and
before you know it Dante's entire torso
is just gone it has been obliterated by
Yami's attack even Yami is surprised at
his own attack and even he didn't expect
it to become a projectile that shoots
out at Dante from a distance all of
that's left of Dante's body now are his
arms legs and head and if this were any
other villain I would say that this dude
is pretty freakin dead under normal
circumstances there is no coming back
from an injury like this
however dante is possessed by a
high-ranked demon and he has already
shown himself to be capable of healing
even the most unsurvivable wounds in the
past so you just never know we can
count Dante out just yet but that
doesn't take anything away from the pure
awesomeness that is our boy Yami suka
hito I absolutely love Yami he is one of
my favorite characters along with hasta
and meadow Leona and whenever Yami is
involved in the story in any major way
he just makes the story that much better
he never disappoints Yami vowed to
surpass his limits in order to protect
his comrades and the entire human world
and he did exactly that by condensing
his mana to an unprecedented extent he
created a dark magic spell that
surprised even him it is a spell that
managed to obliterate most of Dante's
body in mere seconds whether Dante
manages to recover from this or not and
let's face it he probably will we can't
neglect to appreciate the extent of Yami
strength and we also have to appreciate
the extent of his ability to improve and
evolve in real time especially during
high-stakes battles like this one man
what an awesome chapter and by the way
it is worth noting that hasta is
conscious again and that he is watching
the fight from the sidelines so it is
possible that hasta will be joining the
fight once again within the next few
chapters definitely let me know what you
guys think what is going to happen next
in the Yami versus Dante battle is Dante
going to recover as I'm sure we're all
expecting him to or will Tabata surprise
us and actually kill off Dante also how
powerful is Yami when he surpasses his
limits in this way is he actually on the
level of a full power demon magic user
is he a bit under that level is even
stronger than them definitely let me
know finally what was all that about
Austin's demon Dante didn't seem to know
whether Austin's demon works in the same
way that his demon does so could that
mean that osdas demon is special because
it isn't divided between two worlds
could it be that hasta will learn to
unlock more of his demons power than the
dark triad or is there something else
going on with Austin's demon something
that Dante can sense but we don't yet
understand
don't be shy definitely share your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more black louver content here on
the channel please leave a like to let
me know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't had a chance to subscribe
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking that
Bell and then selecting the option that
says oh if you don't do that you're
gonna miss a lot of our videos even if
you're subscribed
it's just how YouTube works you can also
check me out on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar I want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to a friend a a
disciple of Lord Twigg Oh himself and I
can't forget all of our the one to your
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world Steelers acquired respect
Pat a heffa Jonathan King deci D Brandon
Avila's Papa Smurf the school bus King
riser Emperor Taku Ritchie Martinez and
Thomas Jones and of course another big
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius Anatole Kazansky on hell
Cruz cricket XP Joe Stanton very Gucci
Alecia ahktar Jessica Calif on he no
come Ian water Bonnie parks Zoda are
twelve rothwyn de hora Emperor cynical
Kraken full cast 77 and deadly Saint if
you enjoy our videos then you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]